voilà on m'a demandé de faire une petite
vidéo pour vous annoncer que je vais
venir jouer mon spectacle à la Réunion
au mois de septembre enfin moi à la base
je savais même pas que j'allais jouer
mon spectacle moi je pensais que c'était
vraiment juste quelques jours pour me
détendre pour me féliciter de ma tournée
mais bon voilà je suis ravi d'apprendre
que je vais travailler pendant ces
quelques jours à la Réunion enfin si
vous venez parce que si par exemple vous
aviez d'autres choses à faire je veux
dire si par exemple la salle était vide
bon je pense que je trouverai de quoi
m'occuper pendant ces quelques jours à
la Réunion mais bon en tout cas cette
vidéo c'est pour faire ma promo donc
vous pouvez dès à présent réserver ce
sera donc que le
septembre au théâtre
dans la ville voilà j'espère vous y voir
je vous embrasse